my mind has been blown recently why uh
I'll tell you that's the beauty of this
format I'm so glad I asked you wouldn't
have done anything no you know what had
you not asked yeah I'd be unable to say
yeah so uh thank you sir
um sorry I was I I was walking down the
street in my neighborhood
and I know that you've all seen these or
I think a lot of you have seen these but
uh and I've seen them out of the corner
of my eye when I'm driving but this is
the first time I've been on foot
and this little cart
came skittering by that it's a robotic
delivery system oh yeah and it said Coco
on the side which by the way is
copyright infringement yeah oh I'm gonna
[ __ ] take that little robot to court
I want to take not the company I want to
take the robot to court I want to see
the robot being sworn in in a deposition
I'm a little robot art yeah it has a
little robot arm and it's probably and
you know what I love is whatever it was
carrying so it was taking some almond
milk to somebody's house some almond
milk and some yogurt to someone's house
and then it got detained and was sued
and it's in court with me and that stuff
is starting to rot and you can smell it
in the room and it's like not guilty but
anyway this little Kirk went skittering
by like
and it's amazing because it it it it it
first of all it made a little it avoided
me I think because it's not a fan that's
not a program I think it's just you know
it was
it's not program to dislike you it just
automatically dislikes no no no it's
just it's like you know oh if it was you
know Sean Hayes I'd be like you know
we'd follow me along right
um but uh he's a big smartless fan but
he just saw me and was sort of uh
skittered away but no it stopped for the
waited for the traffic light and then it
crossed and
um a couple of things first of all I had
this crazy my first reaction was I
wanted to like kick at it oh I don't
know why I get that but you know what I
mean it's this little thing and I think
if I was a teenager and I had a stick no
there's no way I wouldn't be swatting
that really yeah you too you got evil
looks in your eyes yeah you don't you
don't know I honestly would feel like I
want to help it oh and I I'm not trying
to no no I believe myself I really would
I believe you and I do think I do think
you're a better person than me I'm not
saying I would do it I'm just saying
there's some part of me that when I see
this little guy this little it's a
little bin it's like a tiny little looks
like a little ice cooler on wheels and
it's it says Coco on the side it's going
it doesn't make that sound but yeah I
know it doesn't make that sound but in
my mind it does or they should they
should make that sound oh uh to warn
people that they're coming that should
be the sound it doesn't make any sound I
don't think it really makes a sound but
I think it should say
and it skitters along there's a part of
me that wants to kick at it but then
there was another part of me that
thought
wait a minute you know Sona of course
you've been very busy you have twin boys
beautiful boys you're very busy with
them and you're also busy of course with
your own projects sort of I don't like
how you said that all like no no no no
I'm not laughing I'm just saying you
giggled a little I didn't giggle it was
more like you have these projects that
are sort of built built up he hesitated
I don't know bill whatever built off my
back you're standing on my shoulders
you're standing on the shoulders it's
Giants yeah we're a Giants I suppose
um anyway just physically please uh
anyway you've got this book so you've
got a lot going on and so David hopping
has been filling in for you and he's
sort of does the day-to-day stuff you
help a lot you still do a lot you still
intervene a lot uh but um you intervene
occasionally you've held several
interventions for me
nicer what are you doing right now no no
what I'm saying is that data hopping
we're taking a long road to get to David
hopping is now the assistant yeah he is
and does a lot of day-to-day things and
I thought what if I replace David with
one of these little robots a little Coco
yes because David I mean he's not
expensive but he's it's still not cheap
you know
um I mean it costs something he's
he's it has to be above minimum wage
right it is yeah yeah legally well
slightly above uh you have no idea you
pay anybody I have no idea maybe just
rob you yeah it's a huge I I realized
that I just put cash out in a big bowl
and I say everyone take what you need
yeah and the Bull's constantly running
out and I just keep filling it I get a
daily visit from Coco just full of cash
yeah
oh hi Coco how are you he has no idea
um no it's more like he has no idea
anywho my point is what if I replace
David hopping with one of these little
robots and big Coco and little Coco yes
then it's Conan and his little pal
robotic Coco because most the things I
have David do let's be honest are I
could you get me an iced coffee before
the podcast little Coco
goes and gets the iced coffee and then
comes back because they reverse sound
and then
um you know okay I you know Sonny you
know that my needs aren't great every
now and then he needs to go to the
drugstore to get me some Lipitor yeah
your prescription plant cholesterol low
why do you say that sexually you know
what I mean keep that cholesterol alone
just both the that's my bedroom your
delivery you know it's just funny
because my wife doesn't find it sexy I
was I was convinced I come into the
bedroom at night and said just took my
Lipitor and then I say to keep that
cholesterol and then I drop my silk robe
oh God no but I'm fully I'm fully I'm
fully clothed underneath oh
yeah I'm like someone that goes to the
barber I have a robe over me and then I
drop it and then I'm I'm wearing a
three-piece suit I climb into bed and I
leave the shoes on so I'm very chased
but my point is yeah
what do you think do I how do I what do
I think about you replacing David yes
David will find other work he's like
we're getting rid of David completely in
this scenario and you're replacing him
with a robot yeah hey is David out there
can David come in David David get in
here are you gonna are you gonna fire
him right well no I'm not gonna fire him
I'm going to let him go oh okay with the
severance David come on in and sit here
for a second don't come in run away yeah
you should
you should
David
get up to the mic please
have you been with me when we've seen
one of those little cocoa wagons go by
the delivery wagons have you seen them
yourself the little yeah uh it looks
like a little ice chest or something a
little bin a little container on Wheels
and it sort of goes and it goes along
the street carrying its goods okay no
but have you seen them yeah I have yeah
I'm nervous where this is going no no
I'm just saying that uh I like you
you're doing a great job thank you but
I'm thinking of replacing you with one
of those
like firing me well it's I'm not firing
you what about Jeff hold on a second
what about Jeff you know please Jeff
Ross doesn't come into this this is just
about me and you okay what I'm telling
you is I'm not firing you okay I'm gonna
give you a six week period where you
still get paid and then you're no longer
paid
and you don't work for me
everyone has their own definition but
it's not I call that a quietly putting
you to sleep
weird
anyway then don't you think most the
tasks I have you do can you go get me
some coffee can you do this that little
robot that we all see wandering the
Streets of L.A it could do those things
couldn't it I think you're needier than
you think you are
like it can't bolster your ego yeah they
don't bolster my ego no they don't tell
me oh that was a really funny podcast no
they don't say great job boss no they
don't say you're the funniest of all
time
we don't say that
I might have a solution for this David
if you could just adopt the sound maybe
that would satisfy all people so try
that out
what if we just hire the robot to assist
me in assisting someone and assisting
you
so that you still keep your job okay
Sona keeps her job everyone keeps their
job but the robot assists you I have one
request we need to figure out a way that
the robot can say you're the best talk
show host of all time we could do that
killer podcast last night God you look
young
robe boy you look [ __ ]
you say you look [ __ ] I was online
and they say you have big dick energy
oh look at that ass you've got an ass
for days okay this took a turn forget
those other ones although I do want the
bde uh
dude you're good with your hands and
kind of crafty do you think there's a
way we could we could do yeah we could
do a little recording and then every
time it senses you it would just say
that anytime you entered its field of
vision right right and we could probably
keep adding stuff to it absolutely you
just seem to get younger
yes yes your older comedy is better than
your younger comedy
you're more relevant than ever
I was just talking to some 18 year olds
they say that you are cooler than
uh you can't think of a new person you
cannot even think of a new person you
hit a roadblock right
okay
you are cooler than Rami Malek you
couldn't think of what it took you
forever you're better than the weekend
that that works yeah that works at music
okay I seriously do want you to look
into us getting one of those okay robot
carts okay and then we can uh tape make
some tape messages and let's try it out
as as the third assistant Okay
order order we looked into it all right
we did it